hey guys today i'm going to tell you
guys a little bit about uh firefox's
built-in quote-unquote super bar um if
you happen to use firefox as your
internet browser you may have noticed
that it has a separate uh search uh
search box and a url box
what you can do here is um
in order to all just one thing google
chrome is just one box
you search
firefox add-ons with google and hit the
first link which is add-ons.mozilla.org
it will bring up a page where you can
search for add-ons and i recommend you
search for google
toolbar
the google toolbar which is what i have
here
not only gives you all these features
such as instant access to gmail google
earth
shows you the page rank of the page
you're on once you add it to windows
this is also a search bar so if i wasn't
even on google if i was just in
youtube.com
and i saw
um
i saw a boeing 767 that i wanted to look
up i would just search boeing
767 where i would normally type the url
and it automatically googles it for me
uh
google google chrome which i'll be doing
earlier on shortly automatically does
this um you can shrink this
since you're not using as much and just
use this as your quote super bar in
mozilla firefox so that's just a quick
tip i learned about missile firefox if
you like this tip go ahead and subscribe
subscribe peace